Pete, could you tell me a little bit
about Metrics and how you guys went
about measuring things in the early days
and what was important in measuring?
>> That's a really good question because
you're pretty resource-constrained
early on and every moment you spend
implementing some fancy analytic
is one less moment you could be focusing
on your customers or your product.
But when I look back,
I think there were a few things that
we tracked that were really helpful.
The first thing, and
they're not all numbers.
The first was Dan, my co-founder, set up
an email that would email everyone in
the company every single day and
say here's the list of everybody that
signed up for our product today.
And I remember being so excited when
I noticed somebody from Starbucks
had signed up or we noticed this
big company or this big company.
That gave us a simple way
to jump on these moments.
Email and say, hey what's going on?
Can we help you?
And I think, some of our longest
lasting customer relationships started
through that, so it was a really easy
way to plug in to what was actually
happening with our customers.
The second one is,
it sounds a little funny actually.
We made it impossible to fire
Optimizely without sending us an email.
So we didn't built any way to
unsubscribe from our service.
Instead we said, if you want to
unsubscribe, email Optimizely.
And we were a little worried that people
would be really pissed off about this.
And one or two were, but it also
gave us a really, really clear and
quick way to understand
where we were screwing up.
I think where otherwise some of
these customers would have sort of
silently drifted off into the night.
This gave us an avenue to
ask what was going wrong.
What could we have done to have
kept you as a happy customer?
And we didn't earn them all back,
we probably didn't earn
many of them back as first.
But it was a pretty easy way to find
out where we were screwing up and
so, I'd like to think that the most
important metrics early on
were the ones that help us stay in
tune to where we were pleasing and
where we were angering customers.
>> So given where the company is
currently, what do you think is
important to measure in the next
couple months or years.
>> Well, we're a lot bigger now,
we're hundreds of employees and
we have thousands of customers.
And we've gotten a lot more
sophisticated in how we
measure our financials as a company.
So how we forecast gap revenue
analysis and all of that.
And that's been very illuminating.
It's great as a founder to be able to
have that view into your business.
One of things that we're trying to
build out now, I mentioned this before,
is the ability to measure
customers in the same way.
And to give everybody inside Optimizely
this same crystal clear view of how
our customers are doing, and how good
the experience we're giving them is.
And the way we do that is with
the optimized lead promoter system.
I mentioned this before.
It's a variant of NPS
net promoter system.
And we ask our customers
a simple question.
And we ask them to explain,
how likely would they be to recommend
Optimizely to a friend or colleague.
And based on that answer and
based on the reason for
their answer we get insights
into how well we're doing.
It's pretty easy to
spot leading indicators
which we expect will later show
up in the revenue elsewhere.
If we're giving our customers a bad
experience we'd expect to see that in
churn numbers.
>> Hm.
>> But churn is a trailing indicator.
We're doing our best now to
build leading indicators of
how well we're treating our customers,
and that's a big challenge for
us over the next few years.
>> Yeah, it sounds like it.